DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
The problem I'd like
to work with you
now is simply to compute
some partial derivatives,
using the definitions we
learned today in lecture.
So first we're going to
compute the partial derivative
in the x-direction
of this function x
y squared plus x squared y.
Then we're going to compute its
derivative in the y-direction,
and then finally we're going to
evaluate the partial derivative
in the x-direction at a
particular point (1, 2).
That's the first problem.
And in the second
problem, we're going
to compute second
partial derivatives.
Now these we just
compute by taking
the derivative of
the derivative,
just as we do in
one-variable calculus.
So why don't you work on
these, pause the tape,
and I'll check back
in a moment, and we'll
see how I solve these.
OK, welcome back.
Let's get started.
So we have x squared
y-- excuse me,
x y squared plus x squared y.
That's our f.
So when we take the partial
derivative in the x-direction--
remember, this just
means that we treat y
as if it were a
constant, and we just
take an ordinary derivative
in the x-direction
as we would do in
one-variable calculus.
So the derivative of
this in the x-direction
is just y squared, because we
only differentiate the x here.
Similarly here, the
derivative of x squared is 2x,
and y just comes along for the
ride as if it were a constant.
For the partial derivative
in the y-direction,
we do the same thing,
except now, x is a constant,
and we're taking an ordinary
derivative in the y-direction.
So we have 2xy plus x squared.
And then the final
thing that we need to do
is we want to evaluate partial
f, partial x at the point
(1, 2).
And so all that
means is that we have
to plug in x equals
1 and y equals 2
into our previous computation,
and so we get 2 squared
plus 2 times 1 times 2.
So altogether, we get 8.
So that's computing
partial derivatives.
Now let's move on and compute
the second partial derivatives.
So, for instance,
we want to compute
the second partial derivative
both times in the x-direction.
So all this means is that when
we took the first partial,
we got a function of
x and y, and now we
just need to take its partial.
So we just need to take
the derivative of this
again in the x-direction.
So now, the derivative
of y squared--
be careful-- the derivative of
y squared in the x-direction
is just zero, because y is
a constant relative to x.
And so, then altogether,
we just get 2y.
When we take the derivative
to this x, we just get 1.
So that's our second partial
derivative in the x-direction.
And now you can also
take mixed partials.
So here, we take
a derivative of f.
First we take the derivative
in the y-direction
and then we take a derivative
of that in the x-direction.
So we can look at our derivative
here, partial f, partial y,
and we need to take its
partial in the x-direction.
And so we get 2y plus 2x.
Now let's see what happens
if we switch the order here
and we take, instead,
the partial derivative
in the opposite order.
So now let's go back to
our partial derivative of f
in the x-direction and let's
take its derivative now
in the y-direction.
So the first term
there, y squared,
gives us a 2y and the
second term gives us a 2x.
I want to just note
that these are equal.
In fact, the mixed
partial derivatives,
whether you take them in the
xy order or the yx order,
for the sorts of functions that
we're going to be considering
in this class-- for instance,
all polynomial functions
and all differentiable
functions of several variables--
these mixed partials
are going to be equal.
In your textbook,
there are some examples
of sort of
pathological functions
where these are not
equal, but certainly
for any polynomial
functions, these
are always going to be equal.
And I think I'll
leave it at that.